Hello Freak bitches.
Well this is one of the reason why I want
to bring this up is because everybody
always wants to talk about
the power of belief, you know,
and how important the power of belief
is. And it's super important, you know,
and said it's a big factor in Connor
success is this like insane belief he has
in himself.
But even with the power of belief at
10 you still have to deal with the
limitations to the body.
Correct.
And you still have to deal with like
what is the reality of getting hit on the
chin. Correct. But the,
that self belief that Connor has got
him into the biggest fight and come at
sports history on if he even had a
little bit of doubt, we're not here,
you're 100% we're talking about them.
I know. So it's a fine line. Say Ah,
self belief only goes so
far, man. Even myself,
I myself belief was so high
private match my skills,
but I was so confident it
can beat anyone in the world.
I'd beat a lot of guys that probably
had no business beating or just getting
through the beat cro cop. He's a
legend. And you beat him by Naca. Yeah,
but like get getting
through golden gloves. Man.
I thought I was the next Mike
Tyson. I brought, probably not,
but I beat most of those
guys. Just stuff. Sure. Whale.
But I believed in my heart of hearts I
was going to be the best of all time. No,
you were a competitor. And there's some
people that have a hard time with the,
the big moment.
Conor obviously shines in the big moment,
but at the end of the day,
even with that insane belief,
you get to see his physical limitations.
But what you got to see though is,
well,
you got to see a lot in that fight,
but you don't know what's going
to happen until they do it.
That's why I didn't fight.
So he has this amazing, uh,
belief in himself and he had a
really interesting style man,
that whole thing where he was doing
like putting his hands out there and,
and pap pap pap and them.
Yeah.
And then throwing off offspeed
punches and then drop it.
And then how about is that
his ankles were so good,
so good and and so exaggerated and big.
He'd get fluids back and Floyd, just
scary, smart. He went, turned into him.
They give him more of an angle.
He would just cover up because you need,
the ref was going to stop it. The
real MVP of that fight. Granted,
you know Conor and Floyd, that ref, I
read them fine, you're the real MVP.
And it did. He came, you know,
his opening dialogue with the hell was
that he was just staring at Mcgregor.
Like now we don't want to know that
that gay Raslan and just like students,
I don't think he said that.
I think I thought he was way over the top.
I wanted to fight to start,
so I thought he was over the top
because I wanted to fight. C'Mon,
let's go with this fucking national
anthem. You do that in a locked room.
But I just thought it was off to
the wrong foot. But I think he,
granted, I don't think Connor was gonna
win that fight as it went on. However,
he, the Connor did have an
advantage. If they went in tight,
he'd even let it get there yet.
Grappling under hooks. What?
And that was where Conor
was going to get his rest.
He didn't have that opportunity. As soon
as they got to that ref separated. Yeah,
it was good. He was gonna
let them fight it. Yeah,
he was gonna let him fight though.
Here's the perfect rest. However,
I think Connor thought you'd be able to
get his rest in those moments and just
never was capable of doing it.
Cause the ref, what's that thing?
He got more tired than he ever
thought it was going to tell.
So the efficiency of Floyd, here's what
I did. I watched it live from the uh,
third round on. I got offstage, Washington
DC, the first two. I ran upstate.
I did last yesterday. Oh God. I watched
it yesterday when I get home, but I've,
I flew home, um, I'm airflow
upstairs. It was the,
they had it on paper view
in the upstairs green room.
So we ran upstairs and type move. Yeah,
it was, but I caught on the third round.
I'm yelling, Ian Edwards. I'm like, I'm
like, how's it going? He goes, the fights.
Great. This is a great fight. So
I got in there like writing it.
I didn't want to give, this is
people waiting in line a long time.
The show started late. People bought
tickets months in advance, and I'm like,
I'm not cut my shelf short.
I'm going to do the full show and then
want to thank everybody good night and
then wants to fight.
You're a better person.
Okay.